hey das bin ich mein name ist sebastian
ich bin 25 jahre alt und wie viele von
euch geboren aufgewachsen in deutschland
in dem autoland schlecht in irischen
immer eine krasse begeisterung für alle
sachen die von einem motor angetrieben
werden und nachdem ich jetzt schon eine
ganze weile auf youtube bilden seit 2013
habe ich mich entschied dass es endlich
zeit ist auch meine serie zu meiner
leidenschaft autos zu starten und ja
diese szenen schott gerade ich habe
entschieden dass es zeit ist mehr auf
mein herz zu hören werde deswegen ab
jetzt jeden sonntag autos von berühmten
youtube ein oder anderen interessanten
personen testen einfach weil ich erkannt
habe dass man auch nicht unendlich zeit
im leben hat und man die am besten mit
den sachen verbringen sollte die etwas
zurückgeben und das ist die erste folge
leute wir sind heute in hamburg und
besuchen den youtuber luca anfahren mit
seinem 911 turbo s 710 ps leute und wir
gehen jetzt mal los dies ist porsche
herrlich anzusehen einen ist es kunst
und er ist es noch ein auto lief
fantastisch nissan ist fantastisch doch
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass ich
brauche wirklich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mainau gestoppt aber ich kann trotzdem
auto
er denke auf jeden fall sticks auto muss
man sagen danke das ist wirklich krass
nochmal ins detail zu gehen das ist 1 92
92 911 turbo s aber nicht nur das
sondern du hast da noch eine kleinigkeit
dran machen lassen richtig
also ich habe obwohl es eigentlich nicht
notwendig ist wer dem auto habe ich
trotzdem machen lassen
eine leistungssteigerung von kaka und
dazu auch noch die abgasanlage da ist es
halt echt also eine krasse anlage also
alle die sich mit glamour auskennen
wissen der turbo s 9 und 2 hat ab werk
schon 650 bis 800 newtonmeter und mit
eckart 710 oder rund 900 newtonmetern
das ist so also eins der drehmoment
stärkste auto das ich so kenne so der
rentner den v12 diesel im q7 gab es mal
gab v12 diesel 1000 newtonmeter was ja
das ist ein v12 diesel so das ist das
sind 66 zähler 3,8 liter boxer also der
900 newtonmeter lang bin gespannt werden
nach dem video auch noch mal fahren da
darf ich ja schon mal hier bedanken hast
wirklich große ehre dachten dass du dein
baby quasi so so raus gibst und dann
werden auch mal sehen was da so aus dem
stand macht das ist schon also natürlich
sagen jetzt gerade aktuell winterreifen
und so drauf da haben wir noch ein
bisschen weniger was er da abliefern
kann aber tag hatte den getestet mit 25
sekunden also genau mein auto mit
sommerreifen von null auf hundert also
das heißt das kann man das kann sich
wirklich vorstellen so also damals bin
ich ja den
991 gefahren er hatte 450 ps und er hat
irgendwie 3,8 sekunden gemacht oder so
und das war schon heftig aber man merkt
wirklich noch einen krassen unterschied
hat aber tatsächlich nicht dieses
emotionale was du beispielsweise bei
einem gt3 oder bei dem saugmotor hast
weil du da natürlich viel mehr erstaunt
kulisse einfach hass und es vermittelt
dir dass du quasi noch mal schneller
bist ja als du wirklich bist ja aber
dass das konzept vom turbo s auch das
dortige leistung hassen aber du kannst
halt trotzdem noch da mehr auch im
alltag fahren ist ja noch relativ
understatement so an
genau solche für die leistung also wenn
du überlegst was für autos sonst 700 ps
haben wir das ist ja banane genau dass
ich habe auch innenraum ich weiß dem
prinzip alles schwarz gemacht was
irgendwie geht also komplette innenraum
deswegen sieht man halt auch jede pose
so wir gehen gleich auch noch waschen
und zum glück aber auch von außen also
die modellbezeichnung an den türen habe
ich irgendwie weggenommen einfach alles
halt so klien so schwarz wie es
irgendwie generell dafür sogar gerade
auch schon gesagt er versteht halt das
auto so ein bisschen dämlich platz
hinten liegen ja man kann auch zwei
leute noch mitnehmen so wir sind einmal
sind wir zu viert mitgefahrene lange
strecke aber da waren halt zwei mädels
enten und die waren dann halt eher 160
großen hatten die mädels beine
das ist jetzt zwar nur sollen torso kein
problem also hinten ist schon eine
katastrophe
ganz wichtig immer die erste frage was
bedeutet es für dich
wow das ist richtig die die frage
eigentlich her
wo also ich glaube wenn man nicht
eigentlich nur so von youtube kennt dann
oder ich glaube ja auch bei dir so dabei
den bisherigen content wird man
eigentlich gar nicht denken dass man
sein auto nicht fanatiker ist aber so
ein autoliebhaber ja aber bei mir ist es
tatsächlich so dass ich halt damals
damit aufgewachsen bin dass man sich
genau an meinem geburtstag einen ganz
alten austin healey gekauft hat und
daran herum geschraubt und so weiter und
so fort ja und das war halt das geile
dass ich dadurch quasi direkt zu damit
reingekommen aber schon immer ein mensch
war der jetzt nie gesagt hat ich will
jetzt irgendwie fed weiß ich nicht was
ich gerade gesagt hat so ein gt3 in den
neongrünen und so richtig heran und ihr
so gucken sondern ich für mich haben
irgendwie autos einen höheren wert wenn
sie so beispielsweise irgendwie schöne
alte oldtimer wenn es ihm in der
historie haben und da ist halt 9 11 so
das auto schlecht sind deswegen haben
autos für mich also zumindest die reihe
ja für mich eine sehr historische
bedeutung sagen ich möchte auf jeden
fall auf jeden fall also ich kann jetzt
natürlich nicht sagen wie viel mercedes
e63 irgendwie von 0 auf 100 schafft so
jetzt nicht ja aber das wofür ich mich
halt interessiere da bin ich schon drin
ja und ja genau also das ja auch so eine
sache die ich auch mit diesem format so
ein bisschen forschen will
es sollen nicht nur diejenigen passion
für autos haben dürfen die jeden
einzelnen zahlenwert auswendig gelernt
haben von jedem möglichen automesse aber
das geht ja viel weiter heißt das ist ja
die frage was autos für leute bedeuten
ich meine ich habe auch
für mich bedeutet auch vielen das schon
schon kohlen ja wie gesagt also neun
elfer ist ein auto mit dem unfassbaren
standing in deutschland ist übrigens
auch das erste mal in beiden kämpfen
leben der sich porsche waren das erste
mal wenn die mittel also du ihn selber
fragen aber selber fahren schon bei mir
mitgefahren er ich bin schon mal
mitgefahren aber ich bin noch nie
auch kein orkan oder so mal gefahren
allererste mal direkt kannst halt
wirklich kann mit dem auto irgendwie
vorfahren bei uns zu hause in bielefeld
in der siedlung phase durch keiner hört
mich irgendwie nicht von hinten an jene
alte damen rennfahrer erschreckt die
sich nicht sondern geht er ganz normal
beiseite so mäßig das wurde auch hin
soll welche so langsam althausen rumpf
erstreckt sich von der leistung her ist
dass hier wo jetzt gerade drin sitzen ja
schon unfassbar also das stärkste was
ich bisher selbst gefahren bin war ein
c63 es den hatte ich noch eine weile 510
ps
auf zwei tonnen aber auch fast das war
das cabrio das hat der fan antrieb 510
ps aber wiegt auch als kabel fast zwei
tonnen wiegt über 300 kilo weniger 200
ps mehr und allrad und so pressiert es
ging schon ab so und porsche pdk der
doppelkupplung sieht auch noch mal
heftig wie das auto abgeben würde man
kriegt dann gibt es okay dass alle
nächsten level da ist wirklich krass
also ich bin aber ganz ehrlich ich habe
das auto noch nie so richtig krank
pushen können ich habe den halt mehr
geholt letztes jahr im märz oder april
mit dem konfiguriert ja und dann bin ich
die ersten 3000 kilometer wirklich piano
gefahren ist halt kein leasingfahrzeug
und ich will den halt so hu bahnen wie
es halt geht weißt du genau und dann war
es halt so dass danach als ich quasi
3000 kilometer das ding hier eingefahren
habe da war es so dass dann der winter
anfingen ich habe winterreifen drauf
bekommen und dann
kommt ich halte nicht mehr so richtig
fahren richtig pushen und so freue mich
jetzt halt auch dem nächsten es wärmer
wird und ich quasi sommerreifen drauf
packen kann
dass ich dann halt mal so richtig pushen
kann ja dann so richtig krass habe ich
jetzt ist auch noch nicht gedrückt drei
auto rast schnellste mit höhe gefahren
ist bisher 340 also ja ich und ich meine
jetzt nicht gedrückt in die richtung
dass ich schnell gefahren und auf
autobahnen ist logisch klar aber jetzt
dass ich ihnen einen kickdown gemacht
habe wieder voll runterbremsen wieder
man kriegt da unter und außenems mainz
ja jetzt gespannt der erstes mal erstes
mal
boah krass cars cars ist nicht gerade
eine minute bringt lenkern sehr sehr
sehr kleiner handlicher katarers
megageil das gaspedal ist sehr weit
hinten muss richtig so versuchen
kupplung ist hier muss man so ziemlich
angst nicht angst aber es ist natürlich
winterreifen viel leistung und es regnet
ein bisschen das natürlich ein bisschen
muss erstmal ein bisschen rein kommen
aber angst nicht auf gar keinen fall
apple ist guter fahrer okay das ist
wirklich jetzt krass ich muss mich jetzt
einfach mental darauf vorbereiten
ich bin noch nie porsche gefahren der
erste den ich jetzt fahre
in 710 ps 92 abs
ja
weil die anlage bollert hat auch schon
richtig geil digger das ist geil ist
halt auch die wird auch lauter wenn er
merkt der wird gefahren für sie also
jetzt kann ich noch ein bisschen
das sei nicht frau becker
da ist richtig gemerkt so untenrum okay
und dann kommt dann gibt der turbo so
rein
das krasseste der den maximal maximale
leistung hat er glaube ich bei 6.200
oder so umdrehungen das schon mutter der
er ist einfach ein unfassbares gerät was
man zu sagen also das crazy [ __ ]
kontrollen ja auch schnell deutschland
machen ja nach links linken fuß links ja
und dann wenn es jetzt durchdrücken
wir haben jetzt das alter das ist ja
unfassbar diesen falschen spur wir sind
in der baustelle baustellenfahrzeuge
frei gelassen mit clowns kontrollen die
baustelle rein perfekt direktor
richtiger beruf machen konnte
ok jetzt haben uns kurz in der baustelle
verlaufen jetzt geht's wieder
wahnsinn diese launch control ist ja
absolut geisteskrank sommerreifen glaube
ich nochmal ein stücken trasse also ist
meinten ja in diesem winter reifen
märkte ist nicht so krass weil derzeit
nicht direkt auf die straße bringen kann
aber das ist ja unfassbar liga also das
ist wirklich ein auto um seinen
führerschein zu verlieren aber so ein
projekt polizei wird angehalten einmal
erst als in meinem ganzen leben wurde
ich dann einmal angehalten mit dem auto
oder mit dem auto
diese deutschland vorbei ich gleich noch
mal das ist ja unglaublich
da kannst du auch bist anders ich war
voll auf jeden fall gibt ja sonst nicht
anderswo an sich ist schon was er genau
weiterhin ganz normal dort begeht laut
control muss freudlos dann einfach nur
bremse mit dem linken fuß gedrückt
halten und dann einfach vollgas 3
[Musik]
liga
150 aber
die achterbahn gefühl es geht hat
eigentlich noch schnell und das pack ich
halt nicht wie das geht es nochmal ein
stücken kasse also also das ist ein
gefühl das kenne ich so nur vom
motorradfahren
da stimmt du hast ja ja das ist dass du
einfach du gibst gas und hält sich
einfach nur noch fest ein führerschein
vernichtungsmittel die leistung ist
wirklich absolut banale leute könnt ihr
euch nicht vorstellen kann man sich
wirklich nicht vorstellen das ist
einfach nur krank wie jetzt mal ja genau
und wir jetzt auch ein bisschen hoch
stellen
[Musik]
das ist hat das geile das ist wirklich
so weißt du fährst dann hast du
plötzlich so dass gar nichts nur noch
einmal fährt der 70 km h schaltet gleich
den sechsten und siebten gang hoch und
du hast trotzdem wenn du quasi durch
drückt die komplette leistung aber halt
ohne sound
das heißt wirklich krass dieser spagat
denn nun lange strecke erst im
gegenlicht fahrer autobahn und ich
telefoniere mit jemandem das ist perfekt
also die ganze abstimmung und so und
dann denkt okay es wichtig die nase
kitzelt sport an das direkt wieder so
ein bisschen sound also dieser spagat
ist wirklich unglaublich
dass er selber glaubt also da lacht die
sonne direkt mit da kommt die sonne
direkt rechts die ganzen container welt
haben die sonne so war das gartenfest
[Musik]
dann ist mein bruder max nehmen uns
gefahren um aufnahmen zu machen und wir
haben versucht ernst zu bleiben wird von
aber so wenig sehen
[Musik]
und jetzt kultur kultur kann ich nicht
egal ich muss auch mal lachen
eine sache eine sache der allesklar.de
hast du dich an mit wagen gewöhnt schon
gute frage also für mich war es damals
so als ich den meinen ersten 9 11 hatte
war es wirklich krasse sich die ersten
monate nur gefahren immerhin grinsen im
straßenverkehr
aber das ist halt einfach völlig
menschlich dass man sich halt auch ein
luxus dinge konkret gewöhnt ja ja ja und
bei dem autos ist bei mir jetzt
mittlerweile auch schon dass ich den
halt im alltag nicht im sport plus oder
keine ahnung was fahre sondern ganz
normal und dann fahre ich halt wie ein
ganz normales auto auch und damit leute
kommen wir zu bewertungen die bewertung
findet in sechs kategorien stadt
aussehen beschleunigung coolness
praktikabilität also wie praktisch das
auto ist preis leistung und komfort das
ganze ein bisschen angelehnt an den dax
chor von doktor mir also an alle anderen
akteure zuschauer die begrüßte kommen
wir zum ausgehen ich finde das auto ist
eine richtige wut aber ist eben doch
noch ein bisschen anders tätig und ist
auch ist nicht das allerschönste auto
was es auf der welt gibt aber auf jeden
fall eins der schönsten deswegen vier
von fünf sternen
die beschleunigung ist glaube ich über
jeden zweifel erhaben 2,5 sekunden von 0
auf 100 5 5 sterne keine frage kommen
wir zu coolen das ist ein sehr sehr sehr
cooles autos der stärkste serien 911 von
anfang an also gt2 rs außen vor
vier von fünf sterne praktikabilität wie
praktisch das auto gut wie gesagt hinten
kann man eigentlich nur sitzen wenn man
keine beine hat wenn vorne leute sitzen
der kofferraum ist nur vorne und
wirklich winzig kleiner bastard mein
rucksack rein zwei von fünf preis
leistung ist bisschen schwierig zu sagen
weil das auto wirklich schweineteuer ist
260.000 euro aber man bekommt wirklich
eine ganze menge für sein geld deswegen
drei von fünf der komfort ist
überraschend gut für ein auto mit den
leistungsdaten ich glaube nicht viele
andere autos die 2500 machen lassen sich
so entspannt auch fahren aber es ist
trotzdem längst nicht auf dem niveau von
einem wirklich komfortablen auto
deswegen 355 damit kommen auf eine
gesamtbewertung von 21 von 30 punkten
und ich bin unfassbar gespannt wie die
nächsten gäste mit ihren autos
abschneiden werden nächste folge kommt
am sonntag leute bis dahin macht's gut